[Music]
in not today news not today from I said
it's a high school story of mine the
idea before the article please so yeah
cuz he told this story
make it six minutes long in my high
school
you know everybody's think the bus back
in the day right but there's this one
African kid that used to get bullied by
everybody in the school specifically by
all like you know kids okay but this
dude literally got sick of this kid
Darius [ __ ] punking this dude all the
time
quiet ass African kid wearing this
[ __ ] bubble jacket everything layer
sweater and finally he just snapped one
day he just stood there
this feels the funniest thing too
because he has like like two belts on
takes off like two belts a pair of pants
[ __ ] sweats shorts everything t-shirt
bubble jacket everything and then out of
his pants
after he unbuckles belt a [ __ ] is stick
and he goes not today my default when
the rice gets hit it was the funniest
thing cuz I remembered this [ __ ] we goes
that kid's name but I will not today
[ __ ] not even an exaggeration they
will line verbatim dude that's like how
I'm watching a Batman movie and my
[ __ ] Batman's fighting one guy and
there's 19 guys waiting for him to
politely finish fighting this one guy
and I'm like wait they just stood there
while his kid took off 17 layers of [ __ ]
nobody knew what was going on but naked
one that was no dead does he [ __ ]
like mahogany colored stick Wow all that
build-up you have first it you knew you
was at home like mad today [ __ ]
he's like I'm going to bring the stick
today for the night before is like not
tomorrow my
[Laughter]
romuald there here's a you know every me
did he's got me fun of me I think I
could eat steak or he's telling his
daddy's that it was like my son take
this stick this would be the stick baby
fun of you you didn't know today
[Laughter]
submitted by flash a horse that was
being transported for euthanasia somehow
escaped and saved his own life oh yeah
yeah it's pretty crazy so you want to
guess what this happened with this one
can escape here's a need euthanasia yeah
why does he put the sleeper this will
soul able-bodied you because people need
glue though oh we don't need glue
anymore yeah we need we still need glue
sticks and share tomorrow it's selfish
[ __ ] you should talk you know you should
go to a kindergarten class and you
should be like hey kids there's no more
glue anymore okay and see what happened
this kid glue there start you [ __ ] its
rice and water that's our glue state
agent glue stick well we were so poor
all our parents would take a piece of
rice is that this is the same thing
they're like you know it's not mom it
worked good though dude this is like how
I just found out that Beaver [ __ ] is
what they use to make fake vanilla
extract oh yeah wait a sec it's made me
ice cream and [ __ ] like like like not
vanilla extract that you pay like $13
for like the one you pay four dollars
for oh what the shitty vanilla yes
that's what I just found that fragrant
it's that cynical bro well damn right
you set up a [ __ ] well that's what's
crazy about it to me I'm just like
there's no way they'd have to use beaver
[ __ ] to make this taste right
they're just doing it because they're
like you know why cuz [ __ ] you that's
why because now you're eating beaver
[ __ ] that's why [ __ ] you so some
guy was like just digging a beaver
[ __ ] like vanilla I know right and
that's the expensive one the $4 one
probably a gland that's there that
they're using because in a beaver as
well there's this other like scent clan
that they actually use for perfume I'm
example [ __ ] is this beaver fact [ __ ]
all the parts of the beaver because
there's a glad next to its thigh I
believe that it's like kind of like oh
yeah is that right professor Jesus
that's used for like perfume too so like
when you like carve out like beaver mean
if you hit that gland your [ __ ] meat
is [ __ ] but it smells great okay if
you're walking next to a river bank they
say that if you smell that perfume like
scent it's it's from the gland as babes
excluded excluded from the so instead of
a skunk
it's like beaver fart vanilla yeah yeah
was the last time you skinned a beaver
oh you know it is yeah well you're
walking by a dam either way telling
people these things
hey when you want goodbye a dam beware
of the hey not everybody lives in a city
all right some people don't have homes
[Music]
cuz now we're all for people not having
homes that's right okay thank you
so yeah this happened I guess by a
Florida Highway some horse he was being
transported to be euthanized but then I
mean he just like basically but then I'm
like damn they and they don't say in the
story like oh well he kicked his way out
while going 70 miles an hour and then he
[ __ ] tumbled on the ground and that
rolled it just says that he escapes
exactly I picture him just opening up
the gate and leaving an adult like oh
man I think that's all what happened he
was like name oh that's good that's good
thanks we'll put that on the thumbnail
yeah so so they don't know exactly how
they just know that so a truck driver
was passing this guy the guy who was
driving the horse trailer and he was
like hey you're your horse trailers open
dude and the guy pulled over and he just
like you know closed the gate he didn't
check this your [ __ ] horses gone
right because he's my drinking alcohol
Florida yeah he's probably drinking a
[ __ ] king cobra in his lap yeah this
is the Joe Rogan podcast that's why I
heard about the Joe Rogan podcast for
sure beaver beaver sent he invited
somebody who's like a wilderness dude
expert because you're talking about the
first million dollar businesses in
America and it was a beaver pelts ish it
was the first oh yeah that's right
that's right that's the anyway moving on
don't worry spot let's continue this
story damn sorry
so wait there's someone out there with a
beaver farm just [ __ ] harvesting
beaver ass yeah that's what I that's
what I heard dude Google that [ __ ] I did
for two days straight
I was like this can't be real cuz I
could just picture like a wool there's
mint grabbing a beaver said God you know
I think actually it is I think that they
just used the beaver [ __ ] because
it's probably cheaper so or what if like
the wilderness dudes are like I got a
date tonight I need a beaver misreads
the [ __ ]
get this on here he's like wait a minute
my dicks little smelly gently' is very
very animal conscious he went yeah if it
was alive it was if it was dead he
probably just you know he's dead what do
you think it was generalized I'd like to
think it was still like I was like his
pet or something like that yeah I like
to think wow yeah so or beavers way to
them another useful this do they find
the horse later so here's the horse the
horse is alive and well and I guess it's
being a horse oh that's Jill I've never
seen a real [ __ ] beaver no like in
real life real life and then once broke
his leg hook three legs so he has like I
guess he got hurt for sure from so now
they're really gonna kill him
well I sure hope so so what it's like
okay so dude was on the highway and the
[ __ ] was open right what if like the
horse didn't escape what if the horse is
[ __ ] fell out of the thing while he
was on the highway you know I'm saying
right like that's what happened like the
horse didn't we got injuries yeah cuz
he's be treated for road rash a large
open joint wound and other cuts and blow
rash I think it fell out yeah yeah yeah
he didn't escape well they think maybe
he kicked it open somehow oh but they
don't know anything
how published is a horse way like a
thousand pounds or seven she is
different god it looks like we kind of
realized when a thousand pounds gone for
my vehicle also twice as fast what the
[ __ ]
somebody added an extra engine in this
car it makes me feel real bad or he's
driving these guys King Cobra right and
he's like he's like oh [ __ ] it's all
over me he's like whoa what happened
he's like oh no no it's fine doesn't
matter or so yeah he doesn't know what
I'm saying how could he not know it's
okay to how we were revealed horses here
when everybody else eats in the other
part of the world yeah so y'all want to
Japan right do you guys go to the the
horse sashimi place a horse machinee
yeah
why has horse sashimi I had a grilled on
like charcoal
it's pretty [ __ ] if you guys ever
like go
I wish I could have some horse right now
cuz it was so good really it was that
good so we had the the part of the
sashimi that we had to we had raw horse
face fat Wow and it was actually really
good because I was a little disgusted by
it you know no it's just kind of like
snappy and you eat it in it but it has
an amazing flavor yeah so I was really
surprised what does it taste like does
it taste like
bony taste like better it tastes it
takes like better beef yeah just like
better beef and there's like the slight
sweet aftertaste to know what it is dude
it's delicious do they say what the
horse name was weather like this was
checkers that's crazy because like
animals that are muscular and work out
more it's usually tough and nasty it's
very lean but they slice is super thin
yeah yeah when they grilled it it was it
was delicious dude like I definitely
enjoyed it Wow cuz I mean I love like a
cabeza tacos which is like just like the
right here of the cow so I mean I'd be
down to try some horse it's delicious I
did it like whale we had whale - that
was very bloody Shamu Shamu see me but
it tastes really irony there's so much
blood in there boy okay they're mammals
yes it's not something that I would go
back and eat again you didn't like it I
did not like it enough to eat it my
brother had dog when he was stationed in
the Air Force
what country we're using Korea's and
South Korean holy [ __ ]
and he he said it was good he said was
fine yeah a lot of people say it's
delicious really yeah I never tried it I
mean I heard golden retrievers really oh
honey taste to it yeah it's got a little
kick in damn that's crazy man I don't
know if I could do it I can't I can't do
it yeah I couldn't do it you know do
horse maybe I'll do it if you don't tell
me what it is
well it's too late by that I do it if
you told me is my neighbor's dog
I wouldn't do it just because I wouldn't
want to reinforce the stereotype Oh
Korean people do we talk just not a lot
of them so it's like a very people who
eat dogs it legal still over there or is
it you got to finally go home in a
minute but then my mom told me she goes
not a lot of people eat it anymore
so people who like it that's a very
specific thing that they would have to
want to go and get in a specific area
right so just you don't just go to Seoul
and all sudden everybody it's like
people it's like people in [ __ ] but
[ __ ] whatever eating possum in the
United States see I'm saying it's not
like a regular thing you know that's how
possum came to California what people
wanted to eat it no cuz when they're
making the trip over this way they would
just keep the possum in like you will
get loose or whatever and then starts
populating oh really yeah they're not
native to California
those things are giant [ __ ] rats
scary is [ __ ] they're everywhere and
they hiss at you you've like some of
them don't move them feel like drive
your car they just like stopping is
pretty good do about it we had a truck
ghetto is being on it shits itself
really he's dead yeah to to mimic the
smell of a dead body
so it'll [ __ ] itself how do you know so
much about [ __ ] weird animals look
able please like eglee
and you know possum [ __ ] tastes like
strawberries cream catch me outside just
doing this do you we all would do I
think everyone in this room would do
ok give me it would you lie to them yeah
it'll turn into a JK party charlie hope
minecraft group it's a punishment video
[Music]